Gators know the legend of when Joe
Flanagan
a legend in his own right tried to buy
the Stargate franchise
but what really happened and what
actually went wrong welcome to psychic
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
when Stargate Atlantis ended it is fair
to say that Joe Flanagan who played
Colonel Shepard was not best pleased he
knew the show was a success he knew how
valuable the show was and he could not
understand mgm's decision to cancel the
show
well they did cancel the show basically
because they just gone through a massive
bankruptcy problem they were now being
controlled by a new company and that new
company couldn't afford two big sci-fi
shows
so they decided they wanted a new one
and in that case SGA had to go it really
did just come down to finance
and Joe did not take that lying down you
know the the problem is
look how big
MGM screwed this whole thing up
this is a very very very lucrative
franchise yeah and that they sat around
and the the studio went bankrupt was one
of the worst things that could happen to
the franchise
because it was a small part of a larger
puzzle and it really got swept
under the rug and I think that
people didn't understand how big
Stargate was I really think I think
Hollywood still doesn't understand
now I've been telling you guys for two
years that Amazon are desperate to get
the Stargate franchise back up and
running they do seem to understand what
they've got in their hands in the
Stargate franchise they do seem to know
that this is the sleeping giant of
sci-fi and I actually got that phrase
from a PR guy that I speak to with one
of the sources I get to speak to who has
actually done work for Amazon they know
that this franchise could be right up
there with Star Trek with even Star Wars
and they are very very keen to do that
so when Joe says here that Hollywood
still don't know how big Stargate is I
think he's wrong because I think Amazon
have twigged I took an interest in
getting the uh franchise
so I brought this idea to a couple
investors and they like the idea and so
we sat down and we had talks with MGM
now the idea that Joe here was talking
about was that they would film the show
in Europe and actually then create at
least 20 episodes of Stargate
ah do you remember when we used to get
20 episodes of stuff that was the day
he's actually here talking about how
he'd got backers he'd got people that
were willing to put up the money to pay
for the show now 20 episodes back then
you're looking at
40 million dollars at least so somebody
was willing to put that money up and to
be honest it would have cost a lot more
I'm really talking about
bare minimum and if you filmed in Europe
which would be cheaper you'd still be
looking at that sort of money to produce
one series of 20 episodes but actually
it would be more so MGM we're up shit's
creek they had no paddle and Joe
realized actually that if he brought
enough money to the table perhaps he
could get the Stargate franchise back up
and running now I'm not home since
certain if MGM we're ever going to sell
it they know what an asset stagger is
they're not completely stupid
uh they use the excuse at the time that
they weren't able to sell it so that
would have required somebody way way
higher up the food chain to approve but
actually considering the situation that
they were in considering the bankruptcy
or the near bankruptcy at that point
that they were going through selling an
asset like Stargate would not have ever
been seriously considered however they
could not approve the sale of any assets
at the time because it was still such a
mess and so they agreed to a um a a
licensing agreement
yeah and it was like a five-year term
with first round of refusal and we were
able to look at some of the numbers on
the show
and the numbers were were
it's a lucrative franchise let's just
say that the licensing he's talking
about now is something other Studios
have done Star Trek has been licensed
out for quite a while now by Paramount
and CBS other companies JJ Abrams Bad
Robot produced The Star Trek movies and
now
um Alex kurtzman's secret hideout
produces the TV show for CBS Studios and
obviously Paramount they do this because
they can't necessarily afford to put all
the money up front to produce the TV
show so they give the rights to somebody
else for a short period of time now
that's been a mixed bag for Star Trek
some people argue it's been very very
successful whether other people or the
trekkies would actually argue that it's
now become a very divided fan base and
that not all of the Star Trek we've had
has been great Star Trek but if you had
you had somebody like Joe Flanagan at
the really the tip of the Spear of this
in charge of this running his own
production company producing Stargate
I don't think that would have been a
risk Alex kurtzman came into Star Trek
after doing the JJ Abrams movies and he
tried to drag a lot of the things they'd
created for those movies into the new
series and that's why we got Discovery
season one with the weird looking
Klingons I had a meeting with them
I laid out our plan they thought it was
a genius plan except they didn't want to
do it they wanted to give the franchise
back to Roland and American deed Devlin
which I thought was interesting because
I did explain to them I said look
with all due respect look at how much
the movie made versus look at how much
the series made I mean there's no
comparison I mean the art in in one
season alone of one of our shows we net
profited more than the entire movie in
the entire 30 years of the show
so why would you go to the movie I don't
think Joe Flanagan would have done that
I think he'd have done something that
was loyal to the show he loved on
Stargate Atlantis and I actually think
he potentially could have done something
that us fans would have really adored
now apparently MGM did agree this
five-year deal but then the bankruptcy
actually did happen they actually did Go
properly under I thought this was going
to happen and then the studio went
bankrupt it's very interesting when a
studio goes bankrupt you literally call
and like the housekeeper answers
nobody's there
this was the worst possible moment to
try to pick up a big sci-fi franchise
like Stargate if MGM weren't going to
put the money in and this would have
been after SG you had already been
canceled don't forget then nobody was
really going to not because it's a bad
franchise but because as Joe said DVD
sales have bottomed out this is why we
didn't get the Atlantis movie we were
hoping for this is why we didn't get the
SG-1 third movie we were hoping for
people just stopped buying DVDs pretty
much overnight
but streaming was really still in its
infancy obviously Netflix was the only
real player in the game so they didn't
really have anywhere to sell the show
now Joe mentions in a second that the
game has changed now Nathan green light
this project as a movie and they could
possibly see it come to fruition
within the span of their tenure at that
studio and that helps them
professionally
often a TV show by the time it's
profitable those Network executives are
gone
so the desire to invest in long-term
projects is was pretty limited
um
so it's shocking but since then the
model has changed dramatically about how
shows can make money and you can now
package 13 episodes and pretty much
almost always break even somehow and
find some distributions there were so
many streaming services right now you
can pretty much be certain to find a
home for something if something's a good
enough quality
TV production companies at the moment
are actually making TV shows and
deciding not to put it on their own
platforms and instead trying to sell it
to others to go back to the Star Trek
analogy that's exactly what's happening
with Prodigy right now now if Joe had
managed to get these investors together
and got MGM to talk to him say in the
last four years or so maybe 2017 2018 I
think this plan could have worked
but unfortunately he was talking to them
in 2013 2014 at a time when MGM were
thinking about rebooting a movie
they didn't want to do it they wanted to
give the franchise back to Roland and
American DW 2015 the Roland Emerick Dean
Devlin project was very very briefly
announced by MGM it was their genius
idea the short-sighted executives were
thinking let's crack out a movie to try
to take advantage of what had come
before probably inspired by what JJ
Abrams was actually doing with Star Trek
at the time MGM genuinely believed they
could just go back to the original movie
and do a Trilogy with Roland Emerick and
Dean Devlin a Trilogy that would have
ignored sg1 and SGA and SGU for me that
would have been complete Insanity but
it's honestly what they were planning to
do at the time and it's what scuppered
Joe's plans to bring the series back so
I am gutted Joe Flanagan never got to
get his hands on the Stargate franchise
licensing it for five years would have
been absolutely phenomenal and I can
only hope that if it had been successful
they would have extended it further I
can't help but wonder if Joe was
planning to appear in the series himself
I suspect he was I wonder if he could
have got people like David Hewlett back
I think Jason Momoa might have been out
of their reach even then and I wonder if
people like Joseph malozi or Brad Wright
would have returned as well I think they
were probably doing other projects by
then but you know Never Say Never the
Stargate franchise is such a big pull it
is so beloved by the people that may
need it I don't think Joe would have
struggled to get back maybe 75 percent
of the cast and probably the crew it
really is just a story of incredible bad
timing for all of the Stargate franchise
really but now we stand in a new Amazon
Dawn and we are expecting the
announcement after the strikes of a new
cinematic movie but a cinematic movie
that respects the TV shows Roland
Emerick told us over a year ago that
he'd had conversations with MGM and
Amazon and that they had talked to him
about a project
a movie even then
but a project that he chose and told us
all that he didn't want to be involved
in because they only cared about the TV
audience
so that's sg1sgu and SGA
I cannot wait to see this return and I
cannot wait to see if Joe Flanagan gets
involved once again
because that would be pretty awesome
it would be nice and poetic if after all
of Joe's hard work he actually finally
did get back involved in Stargate
foreign
guys get into the comment Zone tell me
what you think do you think this
opportunity was a massively missed
opportunity do you think if Joe Flanagan
had got his hands on the Stargate
franchise he'd have done a good job
obviously with a big team around him or
do you actually think look what happened
happened it was probably for the best in
the long run and let's just hope that
Amazon do something right with a
sleeping giant of sci-fi
get in the comments to tell me exactly
what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first and for
small contribution each month you get to
see them without the adverts you even
get a free gift after three months can't
say fairer than that you can also go to
scitrack.co.uk that is our dedicated
sci-fi website where we do stories about
most of our videos and we put a little
bit more meat on the bones for you to
consider please go and check it out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
thank you